this is the video this is the bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
unto you I'm idiot Xhosa you're watching
the Deen show today we're going to be
answering some of your questions we
don't do this often because we need a
specialist we don't want to just have
anybody answering your questions we need
somebody that's qualified and you've got
a qualified individual to answer so
we're going to do some Q&A a Q&A special
Q&A section here on the Deen show with
some questions we feel that many people
can relate to and many people get to
benefit from my next guest when we come
back it's a surprise - surprise - type
we right back this is the theme the
deegeu this is the thing
this is the this is the this is the
[Music]
Salaam alaikum peace want to you hello
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oh you are comedy
I'm really excited never having me thank
you for finding the time sake look for
us family's good everything's good
everything's excellent hunter I'm doing
a lot I'm the love I don't I don't find
a group of people who are praising God
more every time you ask a Muslim he can
have the worst day you know he can have
he just say hamdulillah what do we mean
when we say alhamdulillah basically we
we believe is Muslim but everything
Allah ordained for us is the best for us
so even if it looks sometimes you know
it's not the best things happen to me to
die but I know that it's tomorrow will
be the best for me I know that Allah
planned for me and basically since they
know the nature of this God he is full
of goodness and and love and mercy I'm
not expecting anything less than that
from him so I know for sure whatever I'm
going through today it's the best thing
for me it's something I love I'm
enjoying it if it's not something I'm
very comfortable with it I know Allah
prepared me preparing me for something
so beautiful coming soon shot it's
amazing amazing and hamdulillah that
you're here with us and we didn't just
want to have anybody answer this
question you want somebody who's
qualified now you're the vice president
also of the Ummah group Institute you're
also there's a group of scholars who run
the mga online this is the American
jurist of yeah a simple if Muslims arose
to North America yeah so you guys answer
these types of questions correct yeah I
don't hear your questions yet but yes
you get a lot of it yes but all I could
so we're going to get straight into it
and we thought we pick some questions
from the bunch because I feel that these
questions many people can relate to them
they might be in a similar situation the
sister who writes in she starts off with
peace be unto you
laço which is agreeing of all the
profits is a song riyals - yes and a lot
greets people in paradise with this
greet as well if we make it enchilada
paradise we get the greeting of peace
Axl have they loved me a lot gatherers
there me tell us she says that she's a
nurse and she's finding it difficult to
perform all the prayers on time she says
she can usually perform the morning
prayer in the night prayer and then she
gets home and she'll like combine the
prayers that she missed all right
so she wants to know that she's been
doing this repeatedly and she wants to
know is this correct
and is this okay because of her work
situation that's one part of the
question the other part of the question
she's saying is is it okay to do this
mother part is regarding her clothing
she talks about I am currently not
wearing a hijab I'm currently reading
the Quran and I have found that the
Creator Allah she says the crater does
not stake to dress does state to dress
modest by covering the bosoms and
lengthening the garments but she says I
do not see anywhere where Allah the
Almighty says to cover the hair she's
saying this and I like how she finishes
this isn't this we can take a point she
says if I am mistaken please provide me
with the verse that states explicitly to
cover the head you know she's like
humbly said if I could be wrong this is
from what what she's saying and it seems
like she just wants to know it she wants
to do the right thing okay so there's
two parts to the question the prayer is
and then the hijab talked to us you
first of all I would like to say thank
your sister for writing for us and have
this attitude of humbleness basically
you want to learn as you mentioned or
you pointed that she's maybe a mistake
you know and this is the attitude of the
learners and we're all learning our D as
for the first part of the question she
combined the prayer Allah so Allah said
in the Quran in the salata Canada almani
Nikita borrowed a salat was prescribed
upon the believers in certain times so
and the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah Allah
debris and Jabbar came to him and to
teach him when each salat times start
and finished and he came twice to teach
him that so basically the
a lot has a certain time the hood the
Badger the acid Lahore our motherland
Asia the night prayer the February the
morning prayer and the Muslims should
keep his prayer her prayer and these
specific times that the Prophet SAW
sunland told us but in certain
circumstances people might because of
the nature of their job they cannot pray
on time cannot pray it on time for
example the scholars talk about a doctor
or surgeon perform a surgery or she's a
nurse as she is with the patient or a
policeman he's basically
involved in patrolling and every
controlling the neighborhood person work
on the borders whatever nature of job it
will prevent that person from praying on
time it will be allowed for that person
to combine the hood and ass or together
either at the time of the or the time of
us or mother of inertia in the time of
mother up or the time of ratio but not
not to join the five days the five pairs
together or follow them together now
that's not a lot that's not allowed
alhamdulillah we all have like lunch
break you can pray in your lunch break
in any place anywhere you can have
always ten minutes break just doesn't
take much the prayer if you just
basically fulfill the obligation or the
pillar of the prayer who didn't take
from you at 3-4 minutes you know and
you're done and you go back to your work
fresh full of energy full of blessings
from Allah subhanAllah
so please try not to make this a habit
that you miss the prayer try to look it
talk to your supervisor to find a way
that you can perform the salat because
we all know first of most we are a
servant of Allah span Adan will always
want them to bless our work or effort
our income so in return we try always to
do the salat in time the salat is one
thing we should not ever miss with it
yes it's not make it easy on us in
certain circumstances you know I know
maybe one week you couldn't do it maybe
another day but consistently you cannot
pray at all on time
I would really advise you not to take
this as a habit I try to pray on time
ma'sha'allah Don as for the second
question is about covering there the
hair actually the the verse that you
just referred to where a Lhasa panatela
ordered the woman to basically to cover
themselves to cover themselves you do
Nina had a hidden them in Jedi be be
hidden that basically she will take the
garment and she will lower the garment
from the top of her body at the top of
your body is your head so that's why
that that garment come from the top of
your body which is the head all the way
down some scholar said it goes like this
some said it goes like this covering the
face you know a very famous debate
between the scholars but sister I just
want to tell you there is no one ever
ever in the history of Islam was called
as color said that the Muslim does not
need to work to cover her hair there's
no dispute about snow dispute about it
there's no one Allah created so far
called a scholar of Sharia would say
yeah any woman can show her her 'unless
she's an old woman and this old woman
Allah so Allah said in the Quran give
them permission to show some of their
beauties because they're the ruling is
not that strict when it comes to them
I'm talking about woman like in her 70s
or something like there are seven year
but in a graph something around that age
basic so woman is like 40 she can't use
this as a nice no like in her 60s 70s
you know which is basically if she is in
a status that she's not interested in
married any more people men will not be
interested in her anymore and she became
all the law scholar said yeah and he
they are not necessarily to be so strict
about the hijab like the young the
younger ones the younger one but also he
said well yes 15 higher alone if they
will keep their a job completely it's
better for them it's better if we see
people doing the opposite like people
say well wait till I get 80 then put the
hijab I don't know this
that's wrong that's yeah yes okay so
this and I just want to mention
something about the hijab something so
beautiful every time you wear your hijab
and you leave your home can you imagine
every single second pass by you you are
worshipping a lot you've been rewarded
for it so the account of your rework is
going on until you come back home even I
don't get that agile as a man because I
don't we don't get that Angeles as males
this is only for you for you girls so
this is from a Los Portales name and
parentage upon you hamed Allah we living
in a country also that comma date
basically our religion and basically
necessities of religions so you can ask
your supervisors the hospital working to
allowed you to our job and a lot of
sisters the word hijab while they go to
their work well I'll give you two a few
I mean I'm going to take a break we'll
be right back with more in this Q&A
session with dr. shake well liebe
Suleiman right back I am not afraid to
stand alone if Allah is by my side
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if Allah is by
my side I am Not Afraid to stay
back here on the Dean show with dr.
shake will lead bassoon II who is the
vice president of elm ulmus to also you
are on the committee of scholars from MJ
the it stands for a simple assembly of
Muslim jurors in America yes so people
can go there they have some questions
that we don't answer today but just to
kind of add to this can you tell us now
you mentioned something great about the
woman just getting so much reward from
wearing this hijab and also another
thing now that when a person because we
go to qualified individuals in medicine
to see doctors when a person like reads
the Quran I mean there's another part to
it the the hadith and do we take because
I see a lot of people they'll read it
and they'll say well it doesn't say in
there you know to my understanding do we
have to go to qualified individuals like
this a great woman did she came to you
know the experts to learn rather than
taking it upon themselves and say hey
you know I read it doesn't make tell me
that absolutely you know when you want
to learn anything you go to the
specialist you know I cannot just give
my opinion about medical issues or
physics or I have to go to the special
same thing with the religion you go to
the specialist and they will explain to
you and also this religion is not only
driven from the Quran only it's from the
Quran it's from there the tradition of
the Prophet o cilinder son of the
Prophet source under what the scholars
agreed upon the consensus and so forth
now when you say this car is so this no
one can say like well I'm from the Shafi
or humbly school of thought we don't do
this this is all these great Imams
they were on the consensus that this a
beautiful modest way of dressing the
hijab I was a look at Ori every single
Muslim scholars agreed that woman must
cover her hair okay so this is a serious
issue yes okay and his end is beautiful
like you said you got to flip it and see
the wonderful reward yes that you get it
I love the way you explain that and on
the prayer I heard one one one scholar
mentioned that if all the Muslims were
to get up for fudger
the situation's of the Ummah would
change absolutely because that's one
prayer the Prophet Muhammad SAW solemn
said it's the heaviest prayer for
the hypocrites yeah because it's you
know if you resist your the temptation
of staying in this warm bed and you
leave it and you go pray in the master
something wonderful you know and to make
you fresh you started your day fresh and
basically the presumption when you miss
Virgie prayer you woke up kiss land lazy
no energy and missing the salat terrible
way to start your day what a beautiful
way to start your day by praying going
to the prayer and a lost part that I
said before on a tragedy that the
recitation of the prayer of fedja
is witnessed by Allah Himself and the
angels yeah so could we attribute a lot
of the problems we're having is a
community as an Ummah is are neglecting
these five daily prayers
absolutely absolutely that's one sign
one clear sign of the weakness of the
Sun yeah so may Allah make us steadfast
no spirit I mean I mean moving on to
question number two the person wants to
know he says do I have to quit smoking
our local Iman smokes two packs a day
okay he says and some people say it's
only makrooh disliked and others say is
Haram so what's the correct answer I
trust you guys to clear this up for me
what do you gotta say okay first of all
a small King I have no doubt in my heart
that this is Haram I'm forbid it but
he's a nonsmoker two packs a day I don't
know about your in terms but you know
what our Imam is Rasul Allah sauce on
them I just ask you do you think of her
so solemn today alive would he be
smoking would he be smoking cigarettes I
mean our cigar would you think that of a
process or do you think of Abu Bakr Omar
of the campaign who do you think that
way of then everybody knows this is
impossible
that's not never I can imagine that and
just want to tell you something that
those there is may be some individual in
the old days scholars when they smoking
just started it they said it's dislike
is not Haram because they don't have the
knowledge that we have today how tobacco
is very it's a deadly thing you know
there is more than one thousand 15
basically hundred fifteen thousand
people every globally died because of
tobacco daily fifteen thousand people
daily
I globally because of tobacco this is a
killer machine a killing machine
so to tell me that this is hella al
Islam will never allowed what is harmful
what is harmful and the Prophet SAW
solemn said louder or other are you
cannot harm yourself and you cannot harm
others you harming others by the smoke
by smoking even now Western society and
everywhere you go they realize the
dangers of smoking and they put in so
much restriction and it because it's
very harmful thing the same thing at
last part that I said well that would be
a musical military ok don't do what can
lead to your death or lead to the
destruction it's a waste of time it's a
waste of money it's a waste of resources
you wasting your health and it prevents
you from dhikrullah
and to prove that have you ever seen
Eddie somebody smoking he's smoking
smoking [ __ ] subhanAllah ahem do Allah
Allah I mean I won't see that doesn't
they don't go together huh
you know you smoke when you go to the
bathroom but you don't smoke and you
make dhikr you don't smoke in the pure
places like the places of worship
because danke beef it is evil things
it's not pie if it's not something good
a lost art that I said wahala Mario
about it Allah made the Hobby the evil
things forbidden on them so this is
something where it's a very interesting
point like that the scholars at that
time or they didn't have all the
scientific information they came to this
yes that's why every single assembly of
scholars imagina which is a group of
Scot a committee of fretwell's across
the Muslim world every single one today
in modern days their factor is very
clear that smoking is forbidden now and
another key point here is Naik if you if
you do see like your Imam doing some
Haram or doing something that's a human
being he can make mistakes
absolutely so we don't follow them
blindly absolutely this is very
important yes yeah absolutely you
mentioned you mentioned a story once and
and I love when you tell these stories
and it was about someone who was
at the Kaaba and he asked the sheiks
something about wanting him yeah make
him do out to help him quit but the
moral was that if you don't have the
sincere intention then yeah I can help
me can you share the story with us
absolutely he was saying once one of my
friends he was shooting in episodes like
this but to Mecca yeah so the cameraman
is very heavy smoke so basically he went
outside to smoke and he the chef told
him my friend Tom why don't quit smoking
he said pray for Misha he said okay come
on he said I faced the Cabot's big
window and we see the cab towards Rama
Vaughn last third of the night and I saw
her eyes in my hand and praising a lot
mention his names and attributes and all
this beautiful things about Allah so and
the guy basically was so moved by how I
praised the law then he said my friend
said and I start asking a lot to give
this man from all the thing I can think
of may Allah bless your wealth your
health the children this word they live
the Hereafter maybe two three minutes of
a prayer for good things to this man and
the guy was crying and everybody in the
room crying I mean I mean I mean then he
said in the end I said o Allah don't
give him anything from what I asked to
die until he quit smoking got him right
there now the more this is it this the
GAO said I mean I mean when I said this
he stopped like what you know why he
stopped he didn't he never say I mean he
didn't say why because deep in his heart
he was not ready to quit smoke law and
sometimes he said old pray for me bla
bla bla but you know what you're not
really ready to quit you're not really
ready to quit smoking and if you're
really ready to quit smoking you will
make that decision and you will commit
to it a friend of mine who come to my
congregation in Houston one day he told
me she pray for me
I said I'll pray for you but my prayer
is not enough you have to take the
action yourself Allah will help you when
when you start helping yourself Allah
will inspire you but you will not do in
your behalf things you have to do it you
have to earn it so you earn the reward
of it so what I want you to do this the
advice I give it to my
my friend and hamdullah after 15 years
of smoking he never smoked a cigarette
for the last seven or eight years now
the advice was I said every time you
have the urge to smoke it start saying
Subhan Allah alhamdulillah Lolich about
a star for Allah I'll gladly make vicar
because they don't go together you
cannot be making dhikr while you're
smoking they don't go together and see
how it's going to work for you or not
try that try that try that we'll be
right back with more here on the
deanship no speech is better than to do
that was call people to Allah and to do
there were no speeches better no nothing
is better than that
is it true that if one person I'm the
Allah giving you an ability to guide so
much as a lost permission the creator's
permission that was better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
giving down and this is something that
we encourage all the MSAs
all the dowel organizations the mustards
forget this we want to create more we
give these to the non buses for free for
free for free we want our brothers I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand back here
on the Dean show with dr. shake will
leave a SUNY answering some questions
and we're gonna move on to question
number three the individual is asking is
smoking pot you know marijuana weed is
this something that is is prohibited in
Islam since though it's only a natural
plants a natural herb and any the
individual talks about because I don't
see a prohibited in the Koran in the
Koran what do I say about this year
actually first of all let me make the
this rule clear so we can all agree on
it the perversion of things are not only
in the Quran it's in the Quran and the
Sunna of the Prophet SAW Allah Allah and
also what the scholars agreed upon the
consensus of the Jamaat so don't just
say I read in the Quran and I don't seek
because first of all it might be in the
Quran and you never come across and it
could be in the Sunnah of the Prophet
SAW Allah al Quran you Julie give
general rulings and one of the general
rules in the Quran very clear that you
cannot cause any harm to your body
anything will harm your body is not
allowed anything is considered is a
hadith something that evil people
considered something evil will not they
will not consume it it doesn't matter
its natural or not there was a lot of
food and animals they are natural there
are manufactured and these still not
allowed to touch them not to eat them
they are Meggie's impure even so saying
that it's a natural so that's why it's
Allah we allowed to consume it that's
not true that's not true there is a lot
of natural poison and some of the fruits
you're not allowed to eat it it's Haram
it's forbidden it's harmful that's one -
I said that until
Nelson generally you not allowed to
consume anything can cause harm to you
or to others and no doubt drugs no
matter what starting from marijuana
going all the way down in the last are
harmful to your body harmful to the
society and because nothing but
animosity and always associated with
violence and drugs and and I think this
is well known today what drugs words
looks like so no doubt that it is
forbidden and the Muslim scholars today
in modern days they forbade this and
also the Prophet Muhammad SAW solemn now
and Coulomb effective the prophets are
seldom forbade consuming or inhaling
anything el were basically it will drug
you it will make you feel basically so
relaxed and you know slow and put your
mood they're eating like that it is
forbidden and the prophet of solemn
stated that and the element based on
this holiday said using drugs to die or
using this type of drugs will be
forbidden on a los molinos bus what
about somebody like they have doctors
who prescribe in some states it's legal
where for their sickness they will allow
the doctors will allow you to smoke pot
what does its law have to say about this
if the doctor prescribed this it will be
exactly look at like any morphine or any
drugs that the doctor prescribed for as
a painkiller that will be permissible
because there is a need for it yes but
for you to now look at the Quran and say
well of prohibited hummer not pot you
smoke some weed and go praying you know
he said don't come intoxicated he didn't
say don't come hi and he can't play with
none it's the same concept to say it
since answer and questions what would
you want to be high with the drugs
I don't can tell you how to get high get
high by reading the Quran by committing
yourself to allah subhanaw taala that's
all good that's how you get high that's
how you get hot ya get high with the
remembrance of the crater yes that's
where you go high yeah connect it to the
hands these drugs have side effects that
you might feel hard but then you're
going to be real low absolutely
this is amazing amazing and where could
people go now - if we didn't we're going
to have to do another Q&A session with
you but for I'm sure there's a lot of
questions and you are part of the Anja
how can people reach that place where
they can go ahead and have some more you
can go on and submit your questions and
MJ online hey MJ that online basically
dot-com and you will Shalala your
questions will be answered shake thank
you very much and shelah we'll look
forward to do another ka session thank
you very much I don't my T Allah rewards
you thank you thank you and there you
had it a special Q&A section look out
for another one with Sheikh dr. Willie
Basu knee and you got to hear it don't
disconnect with the crate tour always
pray these prayers they're there to have
us connect and that can get us high get
high by remembering your Creator not
with drugs not with things that have
nasty side-effects and don't earn the
pleasure of the one who created you get
high with the remembrance of the one who
created you this is the way we'll see
you next time here and Dean show until
then peace be unto you